يجب أن تكون الإدانة قتل
كل مدني، كل إنسان
لا يستحق الموت، هل ينبغي أن
ندين أن أكثر من 1600 طفل
ذبحوا في غزة، أكثر من
700 امرأة، المزاج العام في إسرائيل
اليوم هو مزاج الانتقام، وأعتقد أن
هذا  يجب أن تتوقف شهيتك للقتل
تحت أي ظرف من الظروف، فلا
أحد يرغب في رؤية
الأبرياء يُقتلون. أنت غير راغب
في القول بأنك تدين الهجمات
على الرغم من أنه في السابع من أكتوبر، لماذا حسنًا
لأنك ترى أن
القصة الفلسطينية لا تبدأ في
السابع من أكتوبر؟  الكارثة الفلسطينية
موجودة منذ 75 عاما ونحن
نبكي بصوت عال ونصرخ
بصوت عال وواضح أننا بحاجة إلى حل وما
حدث بالأمس هو بالأمس
م الانتقام والتحضير
لعملية برية ستكلف مليون
دولار.  حياة 10,000 فلسطيني، هذا هو
المكان الذي يجب أن يكون التركيز عليه، وهذا
ما يجب أن نتوقف عنه، هل صدمتم
وفوجئتم بشراسة الهجوم الذي وقع في
السابع من أكتوبر، وكان
الجميع مصدومين، وهذا شيء لم يسبق له
مثيل بكل الوسائل
الحكومة الإسرائيلية  يجب أن تتحمل السياسة
المسؤولية عن كل ما
حدث. كانت الإستراتيجية الإسرائيلية هي
إبقاء غزة معزولة. كان الناس في غزة
غاضبين للغاية، حيث كان
سكان غزة مكتئبين، وكانوا عاطلين عن العمل
تحت خط BTY الذي يتعين علينا القيام به
لتوفير حياة ذات معنى للشعب
الذي  لم تكن هناك غزة يهودية عون
التي كانت تتقلص كل يوم،
وكان الوضع صادمًا للجميع، لكن
حجم الدمار الذي
شهدناه اليوم في غزة
هو عمل إجرامي
قال وزير الدفاع الإسرائيلي إن قواته ستشهده قريبًا
داخل غزة وأقتبس منه
ذلك بينما يستعد الجيش الإسرائيلي
للمرحلة التالية، ما مدى
قلقك الشديد إذا
ذهب الجيش الإسرائيلي إلى غزة
بعملية برية، ثم نتوقع
أن آلاف الآلاف الإضافية
ربما 10.000 أو 15.000 فلسطيني سيكونون كذلك
قُتل لذلك نحن أكثر من قلقين لماذا
انسحب الرئيس عباس مما كان من
المقرر أن تكون قمة في الأردن
مع الرئيس الأمريكي. ما حدث في
مستشفى علي كان
مشهدًا مروعًا وطرحنا سؤالًا واحدًا هل
الولايات المتحدة مستعدة لقوله للعالم؟
الإسرائيليون يوقفون
الهجوم، يوقفون الهجمات، لم نكن مطمئنين على ذلك،
وبالتالي أصبح أي لقاء لا معنى له
نحن الأردنيون والمصريون،
وبالمناسبة، والأمريكيون
فهموا تماما أن الرئيس عباس
كان عليه أن يرحل، وهم أيضا يقدمون
التعزية  للخسائر في الأرواح في
مستشفى AL